For many people, when they think of Misery,
they think of the infamous “Hobbling Scene”.
A scene where author Paul Sheldon, taken prisoner
by his self-proclaimed number one fan, is
hobbled to prevent any attempts at escaping.
But the scene we saw in the movie is just
tame compared to the torture Paul endures
in the novel.
Stick around to the end of this video to hear
why his journey was so painful.
One of Stephen King’s strengths as a writer
is writing what he knows.
As a result we’ve seen him create a lot
of characters who are authors, like Jack Torrance,
Bill Denbrough and many others.
These writers sometimes serve as a link between
his fictional stories and his own experiences.
Of course, the fictional characters are heavily
dramatized, but there are still parallels
we can draw.
Welcome to Horror History, today we’re looking
at the renowned author of the best-selling
Misery books: Paul Sheldon.
To fully appreciate Paul’s struggle, I’m
gonna take it all the way back to his birth.
The son of a vacuum cleaner salesman, Paul
Sheldon was born 1945.
He was raised in suburban Boston, so his family
often took him to Revere Beach when he was
young.
He always insisted they sit by a piling in
the water that looked like the fang of a monster
so that he could keep an eye on it and the
tide rolled in and out.
On one occasion, he cut his foot on a bottle
in the sand, and he cried, causing his father
to tell him it was just a little cut, and
to stop acting like someone had cut his god****
foot off.
If only he knew.
The first movie he saw as a kid was Bambi, and just as Bambi
would have to learn to live in the forest
without the care of his parents, Paul would
one day become very dependent on Annie for
his own survival.
During one childhood trip to the Boston Zoo,
his mother took him to see a bird from Africa,
and young Paul cried because he knew the bird
would die in a cage far from home, and he
thinks about this again when he finds himself
in a far away prison.
For a couple summers his mom sent him to day
camp at Malden Community Center where he first
played a game called “Can You?”
The camp counselor would start a story where
a character is in some kind of predicament,
then pick a camper at random, and they would
have 10 seconds to continue it.
The campers would then vote if it was plausible.
If you mess up you have to leave the circle.
Paul was quite good at this game, and it’s
probably a big reason he was able to make
it as an author of fiction; it was basically
a never ending game of “Can You.”
When Paul was 12 years old, during summer
vacation, his dad was working and his mom
went to spend the day in Boston with Mrs.
Kaspbrak from across the street.
This is probably not the same Mrs. Kasprak
as Sonia Kaspbrak, the mother of Eddie from
IT, because Paul would have been twelve in
the year 1957, and as far as we know, Sonia
and Eddie were living in Derry, Maine at that
time.
So it may be that Eddie had other relatives
near Boston.
Anyway, when Paul’s parents are gone, he
smokes one his Mom’s cigarettes, and the
room filled up with smoke just as she came back,
having forgotten his purse.
This could be seen as juvenile curiosity,
but may have been a warning of the addiction
problems Paul would deal with later in life.
He was a heavy smoker for years in his adulthood.
That fall he finished reading William Golding’s
Lord of the Flies and found himself rushing
to the bathroom to throw up moments later.
On his 14th birthday, his father gave him
a condom, telling him to put it in his wallet,
apparently because he didn’t want to see
his son in the army by age 16.
Paul cites this as one of the few instances
where his Dad ever paid him much attention.
In high school, Paul played baseball, but
wasn’t much good at it due to his inability
to hit a curveball.
He grew up to be a tall man with sandy colored
hair.
He didn’t go far for college, and one night
at 3AM, he received a call from his mother,
who told him to come home because his father
had had a stroke.
He drove his old Ford Wagon 70mph, but was
too late, and lost one of his parents at a
very young age.
As a side note, the Ford Station Wagon was
the same car that Stephen King drove when
he was college-aged, as explained in a 2002
article he wrote in The New Yorker.
Paul’s first wife was named Eileen, and
they went to Maui for their honeymoon where
they experienced a luau, where a pig was roasted
over an open fire.
It’s unclear if this was before or after
his wedding, but in his prime, Paul was a
best-selling author.
He was featured in People magazine after writing
his first best-seller… then he ended up
in Us magazine after his first divorce.
He ended up getting a second wife… and a
second divorce.
Such is the life of a famous writer, although
King himself will celebrate his 50th anniversary
in 2021, so maybe that’s just a trope.
Paul owns homes in both New York and Los Angeles,
which he was able to afford based on the success
of his most popular book series, the Misery
novels, a romance series set in the Victorian
era and follows the crazy adventures of Misery
Chastain and her suitors, Ian and Geoffrey.
Though Misery proved to be his cash cow, Paul
grew to hate Misery since the third book,
because he felt the series distracted critics
from what he considered to be his “real
work”.
He also got tons of fanmail, the craziest
of which he considered to be a 1-page letter
from a Mrs. Roman D (Virginia) Sandpiper who
included seven polaroid photos of original
furnishings in her recreation of Misery’s
parlor slash study.
He made the mistake of replying, and was hit
with another letter, this time 10 pages with
40 polaroids.
Paul didn’t answer this one, but that didn’t
stop her from following up with at least 5
more letters.
The marriage thing may have been made up,
but I can definitely see Stephen King… projecting
something by including these details.
Personally, as far as fan art goes, I still
love receiving them, and am flattered every
time.
I wonder if King has ever seen an episode
of Horror History...
Paul is open with his friends and acquaintances
about the fact that he doesn’t take the
Misery books seriously, and on April Fools
Day 1983, he sent a mock booklet to some of
them, which was titled Misery’s Hobby, which
presumably made fun of his own character.
As he got older, the addictive side of him
took a stronger hold, and he was often out
bar hopping, smoking a lot of cigarettes and
sleeping with multiple women.
This slowed down his productivity behind the
typewriter, and while I was only speculating
about the fanmail being inspired from King’s
real experiences, this is something that definitely
stemmed from his real life.
At least the drug addiction part of it.
I would go so far as to say that this is what
Misery is about more than anything else.
That is…
Misery the Stephen King novel, not Misery
the Paul Sheldon novel.
In his 2000 memoir, On Writing, King admits
that he dealt with serious drug and alcohol
problems in the 80s, and barely remembers
writing Cujo or The Tommyknockers, and
Misery came out the same year as the latter.
King feels that his writing improved after
he got his act together, and this is the most
important takeaway for Paul’s character,
as the habits prevent him from reaching his
full potential.
While we know that Misery’s Child was his
ninth novel overall, we don’t know exactly
how many Misery books there are, but we do
know about several of them.
I’m assuming the first book is just titled
Misery, because Paul at one point refers to
it in his head as “the first Misery book”
rather than giving it a proper title.
Other titles mentioned include Misery’s
Quest and Misery’s Love.
The movie details way more Misery books that
we see in Annie’s collection, but for this
video we’re sticking to the canon of the
book.
Paul killed off the titular character at the
end of Misery’s Child, and celebrated, because
this meant he would never have to write another
Misery book again.
Or so he thought.
After severing himself from the Misery franchise,
Paul got an idea for a new book one day in
New York City after walking past an attendant
at a parking lot trying to jimmy his way into
a car.
The project would be called Fast Cars, and
feature a car thief named Tony Bonasaro
from East Harlem in New York.
He started work on this one in 1985, when
he had turned 40 years old.
He interviewed crash victims as part of the
research for the books finale, and as with
all of his books, he did not create a backup
copy of the manuscript.
He would spend two years working on it, and
as part of his personal tradition for finishing
a book, once he got close to the end, he moved
his operation to The Boulderado Hotel in Colorado,
where he would enjoy a cigar and a bottle
of Champagne.
He considered Fast Cars to be his best work,
and the day before it’s completion, he deposited
a $450 check at the Boulder Bank for a little
spending money, not knowing he’d have nothing
to spend the majority of it on for quite some
time.
The book was finished in mid to late February
1987.
A snowstorm was brewing in the area, but meteorologists
predicted it would turn and go South, so Paul
figured this was the perfect chance to beat
the weather and start back to New York while
he still could.
However, he rushed out a little too quickly
after drinking the Champagne and ended up
regrettably driving under the influence.
That’s one of the factors that led to his
car accident.
It happened on Route 9, when he leaned forward
to get his cigarette, temporarily taking his
eyes off the road.
The event that would follow would completely
change his life, and I find it to be a symbol
for King’s addiction problems, in that the
crash was effectively caused by two things:
alcohol and cigarettes.
The next thing he knew, his 1974 Camaro had
flipped over, sending him off the mountain
road and down a short slope, where his car
buried itself in the snow.
Luckily, or perhaps unluckily for him, someone
heard his screams.
Her name was Annie Wilkes.
And she claimed to be his number one fan.
She may have saved his life with the CPR she
performed on him, and one of the last things
he remembered was her stinky breath as she
did so, which was also symbolic, because yes,
she was helping him stay alive, but her hospitality
always came with unwanted side effects.
Paul passes out, and she brings him back to
her remote house, where he goes into a respiratory
depression for the next two weeks.
She feeds him through an IV, and he doesn’t
come out of the coma until early March, waking
up in severe pain to find his legs are shattered.
He’s in constant pain, but at times it’s
more noticeable than others.
She does give him a pain pill called Novril,
but it’s main ingredient is Codeine, a highly
addictive opioid that Paul becomes addicted
to.
His body begins to need the drug despite the
bad side effects, just as he needs Annie,
despite her bad side effects.
I say that because Annie has a crazy case
of borderline personality disorder and Paul
is just as much her prisoner as he is her
patient, just as a drug addict may become
a prisoner of the drugs he or she is taking.
Novril is a fictional drug, you won’t find
it at your local Walgreens or… that back
alley that you go to.
There is a different thing called Noveryl,
but I think it’s more recent and it’s
not a pain medication.
But I think the name Novril was named as such
as a reference to Paul’s other addiction
Novels.
When Paul starts to lose hope, writing becomes
the only thing that keeps him going and helps
him cope with his pain.
Annie had also rescued some of Paul’s things
from the car wreck, and asks if she can read
Fast Cars, a permission that he grants.
The next day, she criticizes it after having
read 40 pages; in particular, the use of profanity,
which was not present in the Misery novels,
bothers her.
She gets really worked up about it and throws
Paul’s soup bowl against the wall where
it shatters, before making the recommendation
that he stick to the Misery books.
Paul is in a lot of pain and asks for his
Novril, but she tortures him by making him
wait all afternoon because she’s busy cleaning
up the mess made by the soup bowl, a mess
that she blames him for making.
When she finally gives him the pill, she forces
him to wash it down with rinse water from
the cleaning bucket.
Addicts are often characterized with a common
phrase: “I gotta have my fix.”
Annie’s insistence that he do something
disgusting like that if he wants the pain
medication establishes the control that Annie
and the Novril have over him.
When he wakes up the next morning Annie is…
NOT OK, because she just read the ending of
Misery’s Child, where Misery dies, and she’s
a little bit pissed at Paul for killing off
her favorite character.
“I DON’T WANT HER SPIRIT!
I WANT HER! AND YOU MURDERED HER!”
Just a little… upset.
Annie nearly bashes him with a water pitcher,
then flings it at the door.
Unable to control her anger, she decides it’s
“unwise to be around him” and leaves to
go to what she refers to as her “laughing
place.”
She would be gone for the next 51 hours, Paul
which Paul kept track of my making marks on
his arm.
During this time he discovered his splinted
legs, which were in worse shape than he thought,
and in a desperate attempt to relieve his
bladder and thirst, he’s actually forced
to go all Joey Salads and funnel his urine
into a cup and drink it.
This is again a metaphor for the extremes
that an addict is willing to go to.
Whether he likes it or not, Annie's hospitality
is his drug.
When she finally returns, he’s in great
pain after not having taken any medication
for over two days.
She brings in a charcoal grill and asks Paul
to burn his manuscript for Fast Cars, the
result of his last two years of work, and
refuses to give him any food or Novril until
he does so.
After a long struggle, he cooks the book,
and this represents one of the later stages
of addiction, where it starts to affect loved
ones.
Paul doesn’t have any family, so we see
this represented by him destroying the thing
that he cares most about.
There’s even a moment where he asks Annie
to do it for him.
“You burn it, then!” he yelled at her.
She turned and looked at him.
“No,” she said, “I cannot do that, as
much as I would like to and spare you the
agony you feel.”
“Why not?”
“Because,” she said primly, “you must
do it of your own free will.”
After this, she puts him in a wheelchair,
cleans his bed, and gives him a sponge bath.
He’s able to estimate that they’re somewhere
between 15 and 45 miles away from the town
of Sidewinder based on her trips, and figures
his crashed car is probably in a similar radius,
but may be buried in snow so he holds out
for the Spring melt.
The next morning she brings in an old Royal
typewriter that he refers to as an antique.
The “N” key is missing, which according
to this book, 3000 Facts About Horror Movies
by James Egan, is a reference to one of Stephen
King’s first typewriters which had the same
problem.
That’s fact one-thousand eight hundred fifty-five
if you’re curious.
He asks he what he’ll write with this high-tech
piece of machinery already knowing what she’ll
probably say, a new novel, just for her, called
Misery’s Return.
He asks if she’ll let him go when he’s
done, to which she responds:
“You speak as though I were keeping you
prisoner, Paul.”
Which she is, but I like how that line fits
into the drug metaphor, where an addict can
technically stop any time they want, but it’s
very difficult because their bodies becomes
dependent on the drug.
This novel was to be her payment for nursing
him, but his time would not be the only thing
that Paul has to give up.
Paul explains that he’ll need Annie to fetch
her other Misery books as reference since
he doesn’t have his concordance, hoping
to win some points with her by sharing some
behind the scenes author stuff, but she surprisingly
doesn’t seem that interested.
When she brings him dinner that night, he
asks that she turns the typewriter away from
him as part of a superstition, but the real
reason was that he didn’t like the way it’s
“teeth” were almost grinning at him.
The following morning she shakes him awake
to serve him his breakfast, excited for him
to begin the novel, and Paul comes to the
realization that he might actually have a
chance at survival if she wants to read the
end of Misery’s Return as much as he thinks
she does.
Before starting, he asks her for a different
type of paper.
This is where the mind games between Paul
and Annie really begin.
She thinks he’s trying to stall so he doesn’t
have to start writing, and he tries to establish
the idea that there’s a lot about writing
she doesn’t know about.
For example, he asks her to bring him that
Webster Pot, and when she doesn’t know what
that is, he says it’s another name for the
jar of pens and pencils, named after someone
named Daniel Webster.
I find that hilarious, and I’ll definitely
be using that from now on.
I’m trying to figure out what the YouTuber
equivalent of that would be.
Like how about this mini-tripod.
We’ll call it a Broad Legs.
Named after Chris Broad.
“And the end result is an awkwardly named
product.”
The idea behind confusing her was that it
would calm her anger, because it was harder
to be upset about something she did not understand.
And it does work… to some extent…
He demonstrates that the paper she got causes
smudging, and although she agrees to buy him
a new pack, she does get quite upset.
“And what thanks do I get?
‘Oh, you brought the wrong paper Annie.
I can’t write on this paper Annie!’
We’ll I’ll get you’re stupid paper but
you just better start showing me a little
more appreciation around here Mr. Man.”
In the book, she punches him in the knee and
threatens to hurt him again if he tries to trick
her again before storming out.
However, when she marched forward to attack
him, a bobby pin fell out of her hair, and
he used it to unlock the door, but it broke
just as he wiggled it open.
When he gets through the door, he imagines
her standing there with a shotgun, which was
the first sign of his paranoia and hallucinations
starting to kick in.
He finds her Novril stash in the downstairs
bathroom and after taking them, he becomes
self-aware of his own situation.
“...he realized the medication wasn’t
just working on his legs.
He had gotten his fix, if you wanted to be
perfectly vulgar about it.”
He steals five boxes, which he thinks will
go unnoticed, and plans to hide them under
his mattress.
Before going back, he looks for a phone in
the living room, but when he finds it, it
isn’t operational.
Hearing her car, he hurries back, accidentally
bumping the doorframe as he did so.
When she gets back, he acts like he’s been
in a lot of pain to cover up the fact that
he’s covered in sweat from the mad dash
back into the room, so she gives him another
two pills, which he has to take to keep up
his side of the story, and shortly after taking
them he falls unconscious for 14 hours.
In terms of the drug addiction analogy, this
represents an overdose.
The next day marks the third week of him being
at Annie’s and the beginning of another
snowstorm, and two days after that, the first
chapter of Misery’s Return is complete.
The goal of this chapter is of course, to
explain the return of the series’ title
character, who had died at the end of Misery’s
Child.
In the previous book, the character Geoffrey
rode for a doctor, but his horse tripped on
a tollgate, so he never made it, and the doctor
never showed up.
In this one, he writes the doctor showing
up to save Misery’s life, and Annie sees
this as a cheat, so it’s back to square
one for Sheldon.
He feels drowsy at the typewriter, and decides
it would be a good idea to cut back on his
Novril addiction.
He plans to hide one of the two pills each
time she gives them to him so he can start
to ween off of it.
He decides he’ll start tomorrow, but then
pushes it back to after he has an acceptable
first chapter.
The mindset represents a common coping tactic
used by smokers and other drug addicts.
They think they can slowly get themselves
off of it, but will continually put it off
once the day comes.
Having a small amount can lead to a relapse,
causing them to have to start all over -- just
as Paul was about to start chapter 1 all over.
On March 25th, Paul is 6 chapters in, and
this time, Annie approves of the content and
says it’s fair.
He finds that this is the most gruesome of
the Misery books, and thinks it’s probably
because he’s in a gruesome state of mind.
In the afternoon he ponders what to do about
the black marks on the doorframe -- the spot
where the wheelchair had hit when he snuck
out of the room.
He thinks that if she hasn’t noticed them,
it’s likely she will soon.
Just then she rushes into the room with handcuffs
and a dust cloth.
She cuffs him to the headboard and gags him
with the cloth so he can’t make any noise,
and she orders him not to make a sound as a car
pulls up.
Paul sees an older man get out and talk to
Annie just outside of his line of sight, and
hears her get very angry with him.
Meanwhile, he tastes the cleaning chemicals
leftover on the rag and has to fight back
vomiting and subsequently choking himself.
After the guy leaves she paces around Paul’s
room in a furious rage, mumbling something
about a 10% tax increase, a fee and a lean
on her house.
She finally takes out the rag, and Paul is
dry heaving as she does so.
He examines the document that the guy had
given her and explains that she missed a tax
payment on her house, and she still has a
chance to resolve it by the end of the day.
Paul realizes he has an opportunity to get
in her good graces here, another example of
him playing mind games to try to improve his
situation.
His goal is to give her a false sense of security
around him by giving her the idea that he’s
on her side.
So he offers to give her the $400 left in
his wallet, the money from the check he cashed
the day before the crash.
Additionally, she’d have to go into town
to make the payment, and he planned to sneak
out again and get more materials to clean up the
marks on the doorframe while she was gone.
Before she leaves, he asks her to put him
in the wheelchair so he can write, and when
she’s gone he access a stash of bobby pins
he’d been hiding under the mattress.
He was able to pick the lock again and retrieve
some Kleenex, which he used to wipe away the
marks with water.
Not wanting to push his luck any further that
day, he went back to his writing.
This is a small detail, but I think it shows that
he’s starting to be broken in by Annie’s
overbearing attitude.
Earlier that month he was willing to risk
being caught out of the room for much longer,
but now he was afraid to explore much at all.
And the reason that he doesn’t want to get caught
is not just that he thought she’d be upset
at him for sneaking past the locked door,
but also as part of the mental manipulation
that he’s been trying to use on her.
He wants her to think he’s still broken
and helpless, so that when the time comes,
he can really surprise her with his strength.
He’s also been secretly working out his
arms when she’s out of the room by lifting
the heavy typewriter up and down.
Now that he’s cutting back on his intake
of the pills, his productivity also increases
and he’s able to write an astounding twelve
pages per day.
By April 15th, he’s got 267 pages, but that
day, he would discover a horrible secret about
his captor.
When Annie Wilkes comes into Paul’s room
on April 15th, she looks like a complete mess.
She was covered in streaks of goo and had a
bloody lip as she threw the Novril pills across
the room to Paul.
He asks her if she is okay.
And she tells him.
No.
She tells him no.
She leaves the room, and he hears her slapping
herself outside.
She did not come in to put him into his wheelchair
that morning.
The pills had relieved his first fix, but
he's still pining for his second fix: writing.
I think for Paul, writing symbolically represents
a substitute, something someone may use to
relieve their cravings when trying to quit
smoking, usually in the form of gum, candy,
or even a fake cigarette.
Or subscribing to CZsWorld on YouT--
Because he's become psychologically dependent
on the hormone released that he associates
with writing, he's unable to stop himself
from getting himself into the wheelchair,
even though he knows it's in his best interest
not to let Annie know that he has the strength
to do this.
Unfortunately for him…
"It's a trap!"
Annie was looking in at him through the keyhole,
and she screams at him if he's capable of
getting in the chair, he can fill in his own
Ns.
The slip-up throws Paul off of his pace.
He ends up not getting much done and going
back to bed.
He wakes up that afternoon, with Annie by
his bedside in a completely psychotic state.
She has a cup full of pills and an injured
rat in a trap, which she kills with her bare
hand, and offers to get her gun and put Paul
and herself out of their misery as well!
Coincidentally it would be Misery, the character,
that saves Paul's life.
He tells her he wants to finish the book,
and she agrees that it's only thing she has
left to look forward to in life.
She then licks up the rat's blood from her
fingers.
You'd think a nurse would be a little more
conscious about disease.
She has to go away to her laughing place for
a while, and doesn't know how long she'll
be gone, so two hours later Paul picks the
lock to the guestroom door to find a huge
mess of dishes and the remains of several
unhealthy snacks.
Her ceramic figures were also thrown about
the room.
He looks for a possible escape method, but
Annie has installed 3 locks on every door.
He retrieved some food from the pantry, just
enough to sustain him while she was gone without
her hopefully noticing he'd taken any.
On the way back to his room he notices a scrapbook
with the words "memory lane".
It contains newspapers documenting Annie's
entire life, most of them consisted of her most
likely killing her patients at the various
nursing jobs that she held over the years.
The final page is an article from Newsweek.
Author Paul Sheldon, 42, reported missing.
Paul thinks to himself that it's almost like
reading his own obituary.
That seems to be a concept that King kind
of likes.
I'm reminded of It, where Richie discovers
the flyer for the Richie Tozier All Dead Rock
Show.
"That's my shirt! That's my hair! That's my face!"
"Calm down, this isn't real."
"That's my name! That's my age!! That's the date!!"
But I think this moment, more than anything,
is supposed to represent a wake-up call.
I imagine when King was dealing with his own
addiction problems, there was something like
this, a moment that made him realize that
if he continued down the same path, he was
not going to make it.
In the late eighties, King would take the
steps to kill his addictions, and on April
16th Paul would brainstorm some ideas to kill
Annie, and ultimately decides on the simple
tactic of stealing a knife from the kitchen
and hiding it until she gets back.
But Paul was fast asleep the next morning
at 4AM when she returned and discovered what
he had done.
When he eventually starts to wake up, she
injects him with a needle that slowly numbs
his entire body.
She tells him there’s good news and bad
news, but the good news is just that Paul's
car disappeared in the Spring run-off after
the snow melted… which is actually bad news
for Paul because he was counting on them eventually
finding his car in order to hopefully locate
him.
The bad news is much worse.
Annie had not only discovered the broken chunk
of the bobby pin he used to sneak out the
first time he left the room, but she’d also
set up threads all over the house that were
now broken, proving that he’d been rummaging
around.
She explains the story of the Kimberly Diamond
Mine, where the British would injure the native
workers if they tried to steal, ensuring that
they could continue work, but they would not
be able to run.
“The operation was called hobbling.”
And that’s exactly what Annie planned to
do to Paul, ensuring he could finish her book,
without fear of him running away.
The mine that she mentioned is actually located
in Kimberly, South Africa, coincidentally
fitting in with the metaphor of Paul being
a caged African bird far away from home, an
idea he had been channeling in his writing
by making the bulk of Misery’s Return take
place in Africa.
The hobbling scene in the movie is already
considered one of the most uncomfortable horror
scenes, but what happens in the book takes
it at least two steps further.
She slathers his leg in Betadine, and pulls
out an axe, which she uses to cut through
his ankle on her second hack.
"AHHHHHHHHHH!!!!"
"Almost done."
Then she pulls out a blowtorch uses it to
cauterize the wound, before finally dumping
a bucket of water over the burnt, blackened
stump that had once been an ankle, in order
to put out the flame.
Paul passed out as she left the room and was
in a semi-comatose state for a week.
He was barely breathing because of the heavy
doses of pain medication.
When he eventually got back to work, he was
only able to sit up in short spurts, so he
didn’t get as much done.
Some unspecified amount of time passes, and
it’s either May or June when Annie brings
in Ice Cream Sundae and essentially tries
to bribe Paul into telling her the rest of
the story of Misery’s Return, which he of
course refuses, giving her a reason to keep
him alive -- at least long enough to finish
writing it.
A foot would not be the only body part he
lost.
Annie’s next acquisition would be even more
evil than the first.
It started one day when he complained about
the antique typewriter, and it’s missing
N, so Annie decided to give him something
else to worry about.
He heard her having a fit in the kitchen,
and she came back with the disinfectant, the
numbing agent and an electric knife.
Despite Paul's screams and pleas, his thumb
was gone by that evening.
This must have been especially painful for
Paul, considering his entire livelihood depends
on typing, and writing the book was the one
thing that was able to distract him from the
pain of his broken legs and severed foot.
But it gets worse than that though, because
that evening she brought in a cake and started
singing him Happy Birthday.
There was just one issue with this...
"It's not my birthday!!!"
His so-called number one fan probably knows
this.
She told him: "If you promise to be good Paul
you can have a piece of birthday cake but
you won’t have to eat any of the special
candle."
On June 21st, another character falls out of
the typewriter, but this time he doesn't dare
complain.
The letter E falls out soon after, which sucks
because that's the most commonly used letter
in the English language.
"E".
Over a month after losing his thumb Paul wakes
up to the sound of a car in the driveway,
and discovers that it's a police car.
By all means, this should have been the end
of Paul's now 5 months of captivity, but we
end up seeing the psychological effects of
Annie's treatment of him here more than ever.
He's been fantasizing about being rescued
for so long, that at first he thinks it's
only in his imagination.
Then when he realizes that it's real, he finds
that he's been conditioned not to say anything.
Because of the abusive punishments like leaving
him home alone with no food or medicine, chopping
off his foot and cutting off his thumb, he
is physically unable to bring himself to scream,
because some part of his brain is anticipating
Annie's punishments and holding him back.
After several moments of internal struggle,
he's able to finally belt out the first word
that comes to his head.
"Africa!!!"
The cop hears him, but seems uncertain where
the sound came from, so Paul grabs a ceramic
ashtray from off the table and throws it through
the window.
The cop crosschecks a photograph to confirm
that it's the missing author Paul Sheldon,
but unfortunately for Paul, the realisation
comes too late.
Dwayne Kushner was the cop that set out to
go door to door looking for leads about the
location of Paul Sheldon that afternoon.
He had not expected to come across the man
he was looking for but upon the shock of the
revelation that he’s done just that, Annie
stabs him multiple times with a cross before
he's able to draw his gun.
This was a worst case scenario for Paul, who
is reaching a state of extreme desperation.
He considers going to the kitchen to get a
knife, with which he could threaten to slit
his wrists, effectively holding himself (and
the end of Misery's Return) hostage.
But then he notices that the cop is still
alive and tries to warn him that she's coming
back.
But Annie ends up running the guy over with
a ridable lawn mower.
"BWAHHHH!!"
Even after watching his own body parts get
dismembered, this ends up being what pushes
Paul over the edge and causes him to vomit.
After cleaning the mess, Annie tells him she's
not going to kill him, but she does move him
down to the basement cellar so she doesn't
have to worry about someone finding him while
she goes and hides the officer's car.
She does warn him that she took the officer's
handgun, and if he tries anything when more
police come looking for him, she won't hesitate
to shoot them and then kill Paul and herself.
She makes up a whole scenario to tell the
cops where she supposedly sent the officer
on his way.
She explains her plan in great detail to Paul
so that he realizes that they're now in hot
water and his time to finish the novel is
limited.
She doesn't allow him to have a light so he
can continue working while she's gone, which
is distressing for him because he's afraid
of the rats that fill the cellar and because
he knows he needs to keep his mind occupied
with writing in order to get his fix.
Annie's psychological intimidation impacts
him again that night.
He can't stop thinking about the Dwayne’s
death and feels guilty for being partially
responsible, because Annie would have had
no reason to kill the guy if he hadn’t been
tipped off.
While she's gone, he discovers that the basement
is where Annie keeps the grill that she made
him burn Fast Cars on.
He finds the can of lighter fluid and hides
it in the back of his underpants, hoping she
doesn't notice when she carries him back up
the stairs the next morning.
She doesn’t and when she’s out of the
room he hides it behind a loose piece of baseboard
on the wall.
I find this kind of ironic on a metafictional
level, and I’m pretty sure it’s intentional
because the reason that Annie rejects his
first attempt at chapter one is because it
contradicts the previous Misery novel.
She goes on to explain that she doesn’t
care if an artist pulls a solution out of
thin air, as long as it’s fair.
Paul identifies this as a deus ex machina,
which he considers to be kind of an outdated
writing technique, but ultimately he has to
use it to make a first chapter that Annie
will accept.
And in a way, King is kind of doing the same
thing here, because the loose piece of baseboard
where he hides the lighter fluid is never
mentioned before, he just brings it up because
it’s a convenient hiding place now that
the space underneath the mattress has been
compromised.
The state police do show up the next day -- two
men named Wicks and McKnight, though Paul
refers to them as David and Goliath because
he doesn’t know their names.
They ask some questions and poke around a
bit, but Paul doesn’t scream.
Afterwards, Annie asks why, and he tells her
he just wants to finish the book in relative
peace.
His real motivation was that he thought there
was maybe a 20% chance she’s be able to
catch them off guard and get the quick draw
on both of them, in which case she would probably
kill Paul and herself.
Also, after everything she had put him through,
he was starting to want more than to simply
get her thrown in jail -- he had a plan to
hurt her in a way that only he could.
The next five days were filled with visitors
coming to look at Annie’s house after hearing
that she was suspected in relation to Dwayne
Kushner’s disappearance.
Curious people, news crews and teenagers showed
up at the house, and Paul made sure to stay
out of sight of each of them, not wanting
to get any more innocent people killed.
On the fourth and fifth evenings, Paul stays
up writing until dawn, after which the day
of the novel’s completion would finally
arrive.
Annie brings in a celebratory caviar, and
Paul asks her that he be allowed one cigarette
along with the champagne that he usually indulges
in as part of his tradition for finishing
a book.
She reluctantly allows it, and as Paul expects,
she doesn’t want to be around when he smokes
it.
So she leaves him one match to light it with,
and after finally finishing the book he never
wanted to write in the first place, he puts
his plan into action.
First, he takes the real manuscript and hides
it under the bed.
Then he takes the cover page and puts it over
an empty stack of papers.
He douses it with the lighter fluid and calls
Annie back into the room one last time.
As soon as she enters, she catches the smell of the lighter fluid and freezes.
But when Paul strikes the match, it doesn’t
light; not until the third attempt, and as
soon as Annie realizes what he’s trying
to do, she screams, drops the expensive champagne
and charges him to try to stop him.
As it goes up in flames, Paul tells her that it
was the best thing he ever wrote, and as she
reaches down to try to save the burning pages,
he strikes her in the back with the typewriter,
which weighs nearly 50 lbs.
This knocks her down into the flames.
He can smell her skin burning as she bellows.
But that was where things stopped going according
to plan.
She rose back up, but tripped over the typewriter,
so Paul fell on her and stuffed her mouth
full of ashes, and she’s unable to stop
him for some time.
When she finally bucks him off, she ends up
tripping on the typewriter for a second time,
and this time her head strikes the mantelpiece
and knocks her out.
But like a nightmare, Annie Wilkes just won’t
die, and he ends up having to pry himself
away from her, something he’s only able
to do because the leg she grabbed had no foot
for her to hold onto.
He crawls to the bathroom and locks himself
in there.
He takes three capsules of Novril.
And that -- is what we call a relapse.
Eventually he wakes up and realizes he can’t
hide in the bathroom forever.
He’s unsure if she’s still alive, but
when he opens the bathroom door, Annie and
her axe -- are waiting for him.
The National Institute of Mental Health defines
Post-Traumatic Stress Disorder as a disorder
that develops in some people who have experienced
a shocking, scary, or dangerous event.
In my opinion, the months that Paul spent
living in the house of Annie Wilkes contained
all three of these prerequisites.
For these reasons, PTSD was hitting Paul hard
as he tried to escape the house.
After first imagining Annie waiting for him
outside of the bathroom, his mind interpreted
her standing in every shadow as he crawled
his way back to the parlor.
When he got there, the Colorado state police
had returned and he called out to them for
help.
Upon discovering him, they think he looks
like a nightmare come to life.
Remember, at this point they thought Paul
was most likely dead, they were mostly here
to find the missing officer Dwayne Kushner.
When the bigger of the two cops, Wicks recognizes
Paul, he can only remember him as “the missing
writer”.
“Christ, can’t you see?”
Wicks asked.
“It’s the guy Kushner was looking for.
The writer.
I can’t remember his name, but it’s him.”
“Thank God,” the scrawny man said.
“What?”
Wicks bent toward him, frowning.
“Thank God you can’t remember my name.”
The cops are confused by his reaction, but
the reason that Paul is relieved, is that
his fame is what got him into this mess in
the first place.
Annie claimed to be his number one fan, and
that influenced a lot of her actions.
So he was glad that his rescuers were not
fans, because he just wanted to be treated
like a normal human being.
We next see Paul nine months later -- somewhere
around April 1988.
He’s got a new apartment in Manhattan, and
he still has to make frequent visits to the
hospital.
He could walk again, but he would have a limp
for the rest of his life.
Unfortunately, after his Novril relapse in
Annie Wilkes’s bathroom, he had gone into
a bit of a spiral with lots of drinking and
not a lot of writing.
He still misses getting his fix of Novril.
On the bright side, his publisher fast-tracked
his novel to print due to the massive wave
of media attention garnered from his story
becoming a national headline.
An unprecedented 1 million first copies were
made, so this would easily be his biggest
success.
He has lunch with his editor, Charlie Merill,
who begs him for a non-fiction account of
his story, and estimates they could make at
least 10 million dollars on it.
Paul tries to imagine himself doing that,
and thinks he would probably start it off
as non-fiction, but then slowly start to fudge
stuff, because he’s a fiction writer at
heart.
After lunch, he walks home, because his doctor
wants him to practice walking for a mile each
day.
So after everything, he really ended up back
where he started, an addict relying on alcohol
to get him through the day, and not living
up to his full potential.
On the way back, he sees a kid pushing a caged
skunk in a shopping cart, which is a strange
sight, even for New York City.
This gives him an idea...
When he gets home he takes an aspirin instead
of drinking, and for the first time in over
a year, seriously gets to work on a new novel
about a New Yorker who discovers a skunk in
his apartment.
There is a poetic symmetry to the way he starts
this new novel.
When he started Fast Cars, the treasured one
that Annie made him burn, it was also because
of something he had while walking in New York,
so I think the meaning of this ending is that
the entire traumatic experience taught him
that he is better off without the drugs, and
this is him moving on and getting back to
his healthy addiction, creating novels.
Paul is one of the most personal characters
that King has ever written, it’s definitely not
easy to create a gateway character to represent
himself and be as honest as he was about all
of his flaws.
We would, however, see a new take on the character
portrayed by actor James Caan in the film
adaptation of Misery.
That is… the film adaptation of the Stephen
King novel, not the film adaptation of the
Paul Sheldon novel…
So join me in the next video as I break down
everything you might have missed in Misery.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications.
I’ll see you in the one.
Assuming we stay inside.